please welcome Adam pally
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay okay are you able to sit let me
[Applause]
let me explain you always you you have
this tradition you like to come on in
costume that's right Connor also and it
started with you just wearing like a
tuxedo and you keep ramping it up and
their common thing is that I'm not
allowed to know yep
hi you're gonna come out today I had no
idea they said you're not going to
believe it you've outdone yourself this
is absolutely incredible so did you
decide you wanted to be Batman or fat
Batman what was the thinking process
here well um this time when they called
and they were like what do you want to
dress up as I was really drunk and so I
answered something I don't remember yeah
and then I didn't check it til about 20
minutes ago so you really showed up here
and you forgot what it is you had said
you wanted to be yeah and then I hate
confrontation you know I've been in this
in this suit for about 15 minutes and
I'm already breathing like Tony Soprano
trying to follow
every breath I'm like Christopher well
this is the weird thing I now have
questions for you that have nothing to
do with you being in this costume Jeff
okay yeah that we just proceed are you
comfortable doing that
yeah it really just came here to talk to
you okay so you move
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you